foreign
I wish I had gone with my instinct the
first time I injected heroin
I would tell myself leave it
[Music]
I have been as low as you
can go and you can't go any further
I don't want to be that example for my
daughter
[Music]
I can't be dead on my bathroom before
because that's not fair to her
in 2020 Serene who asked that we not use
her last name reached out to two
brothers named Rory and Ryan Van Tynan
based in Waterbury Vermont they had
started a non-profit with the goal of
building a community that can help
people to overcome addiction and improve
their Mental Health
I contacted Rory and Ryan as I had seen
an article called cultivating
connections and I had read both their
stories Rory had taken the psychedelic
drug Ayahuasca in 2019 which was a
last-ditch attempt to overcome a 10-year
heroin addiction that it derailed his
life neither Ryan nor Rory believe that
hallucinogens are a cure-all but without
the Ayahuasca he'd either still be using
or he'd be dead the key was to accompany
the drug with the cultivation of
meaningful human relationships
I'm at such a like weak point because
I'm in so much pain
not so much I mean physical and mental
pain I really want to help like I don't
I don't know what I can even help I
don't know but I want to you know I have
that urge and
[Music]
foreign
psychologist Andrew tatarsky is the
founder and director of the Center for
Optimal living in New York City and he
specializes in addiction and harm
reduction therapy what are the promises
of psychedelics when it comes to
treating things like addiction our core
beliefs our behaviors our patterns of
relating marked patterns of coping get
encoded in neural networks which is why
they're so difficult to change
psychedelic substances have this really
interesting and unique capacity to
loosen those structures in some cases
dissolve them so that people have the
opportunity to kind of rework their
relationship to themselves in the world
and develop new structures that are more
adapted more effective
Rory and Ryan have not asked for money
for endorsements they expect nothing
from me
[Music]
I hope the Ayahuasca will help me find
my center of self again
[Music]
but tatarsky also warns that this
powerful tool is creating new problems
for some people suffering from addiction
or mental illness when administered by
untrained practitioners these drugs can
do more harm than good
if you face a traumatic experience and
it is overwhelming to you and you don't
have the kind of support to be able to
titrate and kind of manage the emotional
intensity that comes up it can actually
be itself another traumatic experience
but also one of the ways that people
deal with overwhelming emotional
experiences is by becoming psychotic and
we've had a number of people coming to
our to us for therapy following a series
of psychedelic experiences that left
them completely paranoid and psychotic
how do you guys feel about doing the uh
ceremony next week
yeah sure
[Music]
so I came to learn about psychedelic
medicine when I was 23 and had my first
experience that really helped me with
depression
in the following years I saw Rory really
struggling with addiction and so I
talked to Rory about the Ayahuasca and
psilocybin
after the ayahuas guides I stayed clean
from opiates for 13 to 14 months which
was by far the longest
clean time I'd ever had
when your child has a bad opioid
addiction
it wears you out and eventually you
realize you got you can't be attached to
the outcome
you know Rory has struggled with
um addiction issues for a long long time
he had tried rehab a number of times and
he had overdosed a number of times and
he wasn't seeing any way out
it's clear that the Ayahuasca has
led to some real changes in his ability
to control his addiction to the opioids
mango you've only applied more minutes
you still gotta brush your teeth
my main goal is to not have to be on
anything so I can be a better mother for
her
Lily is the most important person in my
life even above myself
if I did not absolutely I wouldn't
bother
I don't know how to get better
I think you know I've tried you know
I've been asking you're doing the steps
to get better you know you know how to
get better you're doing it you're
walking the path to get better yeah but
using is still not and but the methadone
is clearly not helping if that's you
know what I mean like
it's not helping keep me sober it's not
helping with pain
I gotta say almost every dealer I've met
around tears through the methadone
clinic
the wonderful thing about methadone and
similar substances buprenorphine is that
if there is a physiological depletion in
a certain brain substance that leads
people to need a drug in order to
stabilize and feel normal if you can
replace that with another drug that
actually meets that physical need
you can actually help stabilize somebody
medically
medication-assisted treatment
doesn't address you know the complex
emotional relational you know
psychological factors that may be
expressed in that addictive process and
here's where psychedelics can really
powerfully facilitate those insights
I think this Hiawassee experience
can help open Serene up to the
possibilities for the future
hey
the way I Envision coming out on the
other side is like
beating birth like the way caterpillar
is turned into the pupa and then come up
the butterfly
[Music]
one of the dangers is that people go
into the experience with unrealistic
expectations for cure
and I think this is a big problem
because of all of the hype about
psychedelics
and go through the experience feeling
no cure
and maybe feeling worse
and that that can really precipitate you
know profound
um depressions and suicidality so proper
preparation you know measured
expectations or even no expectations
that is to go into the experience as an
experience that
um you know you'll discover what it will
be like
you're gonna have this sleeping bag sure
I'll be here are you there thank you
all right
Joyce up
delish
stringent hey
oh
[Music]
thank you
I saw you
foreign
thank you
when you look at that scene how do you
respond as a psychotherapist
my sense is that
you know they are
very very well-meaning
kind supportive caring seem to have had
their own experiences that were very
positive and they wanted to pass this on
and share this with serene but these
guys are not therapists I don't believe
that they have any training or any
capability of dealing with you know
serious the emergence of serious painful
experiences that could be overwhelming
re-traumatizing and could even manifest
in a psychotic kind of experience
and uh
really dangerous Behavior so they're
completely inequipped to do that a b
they were also taking the substance a
lot of people will not say these These
Are Powerful substances with you know
negative potential so they should be
banned but rather they should be heavily
restricted to a class of therapists or
doctors or authorities who know what
they're doing
um
what do you think about that
as a
psychotherapist and as a psychedelic
assisted therapist
um I believe that psychedelic assisted
therapy should be performed by very
well-trained therapists
so you know they weren't equipped
they're not you know professionally
trained they were themselves intoxicated
but prohibition only creates problems
for people people are going to use drugs
if they want to use drugs they'll find
them on the Internet they'll find them
in the park they'll find them with their
friends
so the more help and support and and
information we can make available to
people the more we can reduce the risks
I'm associated with that
[Music]
[Applause]
me and Rory got kind of Lucky with it
the experience that we had and then we
tried to recreate that for someone else
and it it's uh it's not really you know
just a simple process
foreign
[Music]
are you surprised to learn that after
this experience Serene went back to
using heroin
no not at all
reworking your relationship to that
substance means understanding the
relationship really making the
connection between that substance and
what function and meaning it's playing
in your life and gradually over time
kind of letting go
foreign
times when growing body of research
changed the way that we both look at
psychedelics
viewing them as potential
you know Wonderful tools that we can use
for the benefit of humans in many
different ways but also I think it's
it's going to challenge us as a society
to question the demonization of all
drugs
[Music]
please
oh yeah
what's up Brothers she's very sweet
here we go